et c'est max delmond que notre invité
conseil départemental dans le canton de
saint-louis comment allez-vous très bien
on est ravis de vous accueillir
je suis ravi d'être à strasbourg vous
avez un supercanton oui j'ai
l'impression extraordinaire votre binôme
c'est pascal schmidin g on va partir
maintenant direction votre canton pour
voir un petit peu les particularismes
super aéroports l'euroairport de
bâle-mulhouse pas très loin des
initiatives départementale aussi pour
faciliter la vie des frontaliers et vous
allez voir qu'en période hivernale vous
n'avez pas chômé
reportage d'adrien l'addition voici la
forteresse de une année tels que vous ne
la verrez jamais elle a en effet été
démontés depuis longtemps si à la fin du
xviie siècle il n'y avait pas grand
chose dans cette partie de l'alsace
aujourd'hui la situation a bien changé
deux cents ans pour que cet événement
devienne l'un des plus dynamiques de la
région
il tire parti de sa situation de
carrefour entre la france la suisse et
l'allemagne
oui ici l'europe n'est pas un concept
lointain on la vit au quotidien
chaque jour ils sont plus de 40000 à
partir de france vers la suisse une
petite dizaine de milliers vers
l'allemagne
quand les échanges transfrontaliers est
au coeur de la vie il convient de le
faciliter
informer les citoyens des trois pays sur
les différentes législations c'est la
mission d'informer est son agence de
palmarin est situé dans l'ancien poste
de douane de village neuf
tout un symbole ce service est très
sollicitée principalement par la
population française puisque près de 50%
fait des consultations sont d'origine
française et sur l'ensemble de ces
consultations française plus du tiers
des usagers réside dans le canton de
saint-louis donc une part importante
effectivement de notre population qui
s'adresse à ce service pour avoir des
réponses géré à toutes les questions qui
concernent l'emploi le logement la
fiscalité l'assurance maladie notamment
aviso globe trotter à l'avenir s'il vous
arrivait de vouloir rallier nantes à
budapest à vélo vous passeriez ici la
voie verte trinationale entre bâle et
weil am rhein est en cours d'achèvement
1 km 800 trois pays traversés un million
deux cent mille euros d'investissement
du conseil départemental
cette piste est la pièce manquante au
croisement d euros véloroute est-ouest
et nord-sud mais elle s'intègre aussi
dans le quotidien des habitants du
canton
la question de la mobilité extrêmement
importante sur le secteur des trois
frontières c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément de passage entre les
frontières
donc il était important effectivement de
réaliser des travaux pour promouvoir en
fait la mobilité douce
alors c'est un itinéraire qui permettra
bien sûr aux travailleurs frontaliers de
se déplacer plus facilement mais aussi à
l'ensemble de la population pour aller
faire des courses pour se promener donc
c'est à la fois pour répondre à des
besoins liés à l'emploi mais aussi à des
besoins quotidiens de promenade ou des
besoins touristiques
branle bas de combat au centre technique
routier de bartenheim des chutes de
neige sont annoncées sur le département
ici ce sont douze agents et deux cadres
qui veille sept jours sur sept sur les
235 km de routes du canton de
saint-louis et d'une partie du canton de
brunstatt ce centre est opérationnel
depuis le mois de juillet 2015 et il
était auparavant situé sur une un gain
donc un centre sur une aide qui n'était
plus du tout adapté voilà nouvelles
conditions de travail
alors pourquoi bartenheim parce que nous
sommes à la croisée des voies de
communication au coeur du territoire
lors d'épisodes neigeux ces agents
peuvent être mobilisés jusqu'à 60 heures
par semaine et les cinq saleuses du
centre répandent chaque jour sur les
routes près de 60 tonnes de sel pour que
vous puissiez rouler tranquille là max
delmond est notre invité avec votre
binôme pascale schmidiger
on a vu la ville de bâle elle ne peut
plus s'étendre a finalement donc elle
commence à jouer un petit peu des coudes
et à s'étendre du côté français le
regarde en tout cas chez nous ça donne
un quartier dont vous allez nous parler
maintenant qu'est m'a dit adrien quand
il a fait le tournage m'a dit c'est un
projet qui est complètement fou qui est
énorme c'est le quartier dry land
ça s'agite il s'agit de court alors on
parle prier dry land en fait c'est
l'industrie pharmaceutique bâloise est
un peu bloquée entre la ville et le bord
du rhin et donc il ya un projet dry land
trois pays entre la france et
l'allemagne
c'est une zone de 180 hectares à cheval
à cheval de part et d'autre du rhin et
donc l'ambition c'est d'y faire un
campus centre de recherche
là les suisses 10 un potentiel de 13
mille emplois dans un horizon de 15 ans
alors on n'est vraiment pas se
construire en deux ans vous avez une
vraie vision à long terme
c'est une réflexion c'est la coopération
transfrontalière mais vécue au jour le
jour
en fait nous on pratique une vraie
petite europe qui marche ce ne sont pas
que des actes le tram par exemple année
une preuve tout comme la voie verte
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure ça on va
revenir juste un petit morceau dry land
zi du campus universitaire de
l'appartement deux des leurs alors voilà
ce sera il y aura des chercheurs est
aussi un campus alors scellé
vision qu'à l'industrie chimique entre
autres novartis ce serait comme faire un
cluster où on a on à l'étudiant l'étude
et le travail et une partie verte parce
que l'environnement est toujours très
présent dans ce projet le long des
berges de données verdure à faire y
vivre et y travailler et apprendre et
qu'on entend treize mille emplois
possibles ça fait rêver hein
voilà tout à fait c'est sûr autre projet
d'aménagement du territoire c'est le
futur technoport côté français c'est à
proximité de l'euroairport
c'est quoi qu'à leur explication alors
d'abord le conseil départemental est
intéressé par sa compétence qui
s'appelle les routes et la mobilité et
on a un problème de sortie d'autoroute
pour rentrer sur la rd 105 qui est à
proximité de ce projet de technopole le
projet technoport c'est une zone
d'environ 100 hectares il y aura une
zone commerciale une zone verte qui va
faire le lien avec la réserve de la
petite camargue et en centre et un
centre d'affaires
il est évident que s'il ya des milliers
d'emplois à la clef il va y avoir des
flux de circulation à gérer et le
département est effectivement partie
prenante
en fait on est là dans de la mobilité
c'est déjà difficile maintenant comment
ça va être demain sans ce sens là que
nous sommes présents dans ce projet mais
pour la partie mobilité en 2017 les
premiers trams entre saint louis et bals
seront en circulation c'était important
pour le département de participer à ce
projet oui c'était important alors
autant pour la partie suisse pour la
partie française
on relie le centre de ville de bâle à la
gare à la gare de saint louis
on a un problème de circulation origine
tout à l'heure par le tram
les études montrent que mécaniquement
dès que le tram est en marche c'est
environ deux mille voitures en moins
souvent ce qu'on sent dans la
circulation
c'est peut-être pas lady plaidé d'élite
des dix premiers milliers de voitures
c'est ce qui en plus qui ne passe plus
et si on soustrait 2000 c'est déjà ça
un peu de vélo voilà et on arrive à ce
que ça soit peut être vivable démarche
écologique 6 voilà bien entendu il ya
toujours une démarche écologique en
région transfrontalière
il ya la culture on va dire peut-être un
peu plus avancés que nous culture suisse
qui nous impose sa en alsace sur les
quais mais aussi bien en avance par
rapport à d'autres régions françaises
alors là où certains peuvent râler c'est
sur les services sociaux beaucoup de
gens se plaignent un petit peu de
l'éclatement des services sociaux vous
vous avez une solution alors vous avez
raison les gens se plaignent le social
c'est la compétence le coeur de métier
du département 50% du budget c'est les
personnes âgées c'est les enfants c'est
l'aide sociale selon rsa et chaque
service a éclaté dans la éclaté dans la
ville
souvent ils ont peut être eu une
personne âgée une personne âgée et avoir
besoin d'être social pour pas et on
n'avait aucune phase 2 perd quand même
donc il faut réunir tous ces services en
un seul et même endroit
il s'avère que la ville de saint louis à
un projet d'urbanisation d'un secteur et
nous département dès que dès que le
permis sera déposée ça peut être fin
2020 2016
nous avons on va dire l'ambition de
regrouper tous le savent tous nos
services sur 800 mètres carrés donc plus
efficace pour l'étranger sont uniques
voila voila doute à fond à peu près tout
sous la main tout ce qui va concerner
concerné la solidarité donc plus rapide
pour l'usagé plus efficace et aussi plus
économe puisqu'il ya pas de perte
d'énergie en ligne alors plus économe
c'est à dire que les trente et une
personnes qui travaillent au quotidien
même si on a un peu plus de travail
parce que la population va augmenter
on va pouvoir faire face et on est plus
efficace mcdem en dernier point on va
quitter sa vie d'abord pour l'essai du
côté de hégenheim
il est prévu qu'on irait 9 le collège
des trois pays c'était une prévision qui
du concret de maintenant alors c'est un
projet qui me tient qui me tient à coeur
le collège d'hégenheim bombe c'est un
collège qui accueille 7 700 à 750 élèves
depuis on va dire 2011 ma première prise
de fonction on en parle delà de la mise
en accessibilité de la rénovation en
2013 1014 la décision politique a été
prise que c'était il fallait faire des
travaux maintenant il ya les arbitrages
budgétaires alors politiquement on va le
faire
le camp dernières nouvelles en angèle
tous les grands projets jusqu'en 2018
alors c'est pas forcément agréables à
entendre surtout surtout au moins et
noir étaient en a mais il faut dire les
choses
ça n'empêche ça n'empêche que tous les
projets de maintenance lourde tous les
ans va faire quelque chose voilà merci
max delmond d'être passé sur le plateau
d'alsace